yeah there's times where deer will eat
like a [__] um like a rabbit like a
rabbit yeah or some [__] like that yep
it's crazy I saw one of a bear going
into a 7-Eleven he'd steal snowballs
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys we got Chappelle back hey
Chappelle and we got Nick's kids these
kids are here
and today we are going to share
our favorite ways to waste time
I think on my phone
I always go to the airport with a fully
charged phone
so that if I need to kill time I could
just go
what do you watch specifically yeah
what's wasting it honestly like just
Instagram just [__] aimless mindless
mindless scroll is probably the most
popular most popular but you're never in
the mood like sometimes I'm in a natural
disaster mood or like a shootout mood
for like wanna see some flooding robbery
fail Moon flooding is good Robbie Phil
oh those are good to watch Amazon
package sabotage like the whole that's a
good glitter bomb here's a here's a
unique deep cut I like to look up old
Nintendo manuals from when I was a kid
from the games I owned to see if my
memory matches up with what I saw when I
was a kid what you're so used I'll look
up Double Dragon of like 1989 and
remember the manual and go oh yeah I
remember it showed these stats and it
showed diagrams and I look them up
online because they're all in databases
now and there's like hundreds and I just
go wow I didn't remember that correctly
you know and I do that for hours
that's a strong one
remember the coach you would have to
type in on like Mortal Kombat the Konami
codes yeah just to do a fatality oh yeah
yeah back in the day yeah I love to say
I'd love to see if I'm Mandela effecting
that's like a hobby of mine to go like
am I seeing it differently in my head or
is it well they say like 50 of your
memories a lot and on top of that your
memory is the memory of the last time
you thought about it not the actual
event so that's like why it's like
playing telephone with your mind yeah
that's why it's like always wrong yeah
but we can trust our women's testimony
though
you know what I get addicted to watching
watching there's two things it's always
animal [__] too oh dudes animals in the
wild like eating each other yeah and
then hunting videos which meanwhile I
would never [__] hunt I would never
shoot an animal no she's a vegetarian
yeah but I sit here and watch these
because it's like it's interesting like
the sniper scope camera where they just
like where people like legit hunt their
food they're like like they're like
waiting do you watch catch and cooks or
you just watch the hunt it's like the
catch and cook I love catching so catch
a cookie yeah yeah like to hunt like
you're just gonna shoot that [__]
javelina all right cool I watched one of
Gordon Ramsay [__] deep Dives and
grabs a lobster and Cooks it like in
five minutes that's what I'm saying
either that shit's interesting I can
[__] go all day no it's super
interesting but also highly unsettling
is watching animal videos of animals
doing things they don't normally do and
they're not supposed to like like
playing poker like when um omnivore or
like herbivore animals start eating
other animals
freak animal stuff that is so scary
here yeah there's times where deer will
eat like a [__] um like a rabbit like
a rabbit yeah or some [__] like that yep
it's crazy dude I saw one of a bear
going into a 7-Eleven he'd steal
snowballs
yo Bears don't give a [__] they'll go in
stores they'll go in houses they were
like yeah and he kept coming back for
more more Hostess [__] did he really
yeah it's a great he's like Twinkie
or I come out of the items dude I swear
but meanwhile like watching these videos
like especially animals hunting they're
like food yeah like everyone's like oh
this is so ruthless this is so ruthless
but I'm like that's how they have to eat
yeah I'm like that's not ruthless that's
just what it is because literally the
animal's thinking like yeah I gotta
[__] eat yes because like all the
like a bear the amount of meat like yeah
the amount of like food it has to
consume just to like not you know like
feel like hungry and bears are wasteful
they'll just eat the skin of a salmon
and go yeah yeah yeah I had I had a
buddy go on a uh I don't know if they go
I don't know if they go
African safari with their family and he
was like when you're like in like nature
nature like not [__] like eating
Canyon or [__] on a trail we're in
nature nature he goes the amount of
violence is [__] insane like you know
for us like if we're sitting at a park
and there's like [__] a mosquito God
damn it like that's our nature right
like that frequency is happening but
death everywhere so like they're just
driving in a Jeep and you see like a
deer go into like drink some water
alligator comes out [__] pulls a deer
in that motherfucker's dead and then
[__] a lion just chasing a gazelle
kills his ass and then you see hyenas
come and The Lion and the hyenas
fighting one of them dies [__]
vulture comes like as you're in this
Jeep he was like on a 15 minute ride he
probably witnessed like 30 deaths it's
like daily D-Day yeah daily and that's
that's so normal that's like mosquitoes
and flies going on our food yeah but
that's their mosquito and flies in real
nature well they also don't know when
they're gonna [__] get that next
opportunity yeah they have to get it
like that's why they [__] don't stop
yeah you know what I mean I've been
seeing some videos of uh monkeys that
are like in the highest trees and
they're jumping across and then what's
chasing them are like Jaguars yes
and jaguars
will fall all the way to the bottom but
then there's another one jumping right
up on their crap there was one Jaguar
that did like a [__] backflip to
catch this [__] monkey but cats
always land on their feet though
so [__] crazy and then you hear these
monkeys like yelping and you're like oh
[__] have you seen monkeys eat smaller
monkeys yes yes because monkeys will
hunt under smaller monkeys if they feel
like human that's why it's weird it's
like little kids are like yeah and
they'll grab they'll grab monkeys chew
the other monkeys in it but also that's
like a [__] like a dominance thing
you know because they're trying to like
clear out like the monkey with the Frog
when he's jerking off with it yeah
[Laughter]
you know monkeys are involved evolving
right now they have monkey Wars right
because it's like for territory or
whatever and now they're using tools for
battle and they're using all kinds of
sharks yeah they're doing treaties yeah
wait really yeah like like our Bronze
Age is when we started using tools and
[__] that's where the monkeys are now
yeah when the monkeys when the monkeys
start getting into the city yeah they're
gonna [__] us up what's the month start
doing AI
in India there's a monkey and dog War
that's going on oh yeah the stray dogs
so then so then the stray dogs would
gang up and like kill a monkey and then
so they'll like grab puppies and then
take it to the roof and throw them yeah
we gotta kill these monkeys dude anytime
monkeys do [__] it always makes me laugh
even if it's that me too because they're
just like dude like like the straight
face because that's my favorite [__] to
Google is monkeys doing people [__] oh
dude it's hilarious or when people go to
the zoos and they like the one viral
video the lady throws a bottle at the
monkey and the monkey picks up and
throws it right back at her
yeah yo how long ago did harambe die
seven years ago seven years ago
it was last month just last month just
last night really yeah damn okay I
didn't do I didn't go anywhere what did
y'all think about that yeah
I don't think it was needed yeah like
why couldn't they just tranquilize them
yeah does that not having a school you
need a scapegoat they need a scapegoat
for the world government
it was [__] up made me sad I know I
like I like uh monkeys um
um bowling humans and also I like I like
monkey perverts monkey perverts are
great monkey primers are great
they're looking up the skirt yeah
I like when uh Chinese families drive
into a nature preserve and then the wife
gets out of the car
inside and she go [__] you [__] and
then a [__] line it takes takes comes
and takes her away
I don't understand like it's like yo
like they see you as food yeah they tell
you to stay in the car and then you
think you're special for some reason and
then you are special you can take it off
I need a better picture your picture's
gonna look like [__] if you're at the
window in front of it yeah
you gotta lean out a little bit
anytime nature backfires I love it I'm
like you didn't respect nature yeah
anytime I see people like die from that
[__] I'm like I mean what'd you think
yeah what the [__] did you think yeah
that is what happened I always give a
moment of silence you do I do and I feel
I feel bad about what happened hey y'all
know that remember that mountain lion
that was in like Los Feliz oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah they killed that
[__] oh that's right that just
happened how did you feel about that I
was pretty bummed but but I understood
why they had to euthanize it because
what was going on p12 so like it was I
mean it was going around in the
neighborhoods it was like eating
people's dogs he was [__] around and
he found out he found out but they
caught him and they were just going to
put him in a better you know area for
him to like Thrive and [__] well I guess
um when he when they when they caught
him they run tests on him just to make
sure he's good before they just so they
can set him up for Success yeah well he
got his [__] round levels were all
the way up yeah [__] around levels were
all the way up and so basically
um he got hit by a car so he was pretty
[__] up today's video is brought to
you by Lumi all right check this out I
actually stopped using deodorant
um in high school when I found out that
they got all kinds of crazy things in it
that actually messes you up like
chemicals and metals and I was like what
is this and now we're learning so much
about parabens and all that and I'm like
I don't want this anymore I rather stink
but thankfully we got Lumi out here that
not only is just used for under armpit
deodorant but it could go whole body man
like you could put it on your forehead
all the way down to your butthole dude
and it's the different skin too and it
works and everything and you know how
you know you can trust them because it
was invented by an OB GYN so that's a
hoo-ha doctor someone that looks at the
flaps every single day so if you know
something works on your vagina it works
everywhere else ph balanced optimized
and no aluminum none of that parabens
[__] is made to make you smell good
everywhere so I put it here and I put it
in the back of my kneecap I pull my skin
back and I [__] put it around my
[__] penis and I roll my skin back
off wow the Lumi starter pack is perfect
for new customers it comes with a solid
Stick deodorant a cream tube deodorant
and two free products of your choice
like mini body wash deodorant wipes and
free shipping as a special offer for
listeners that's you guys new customers
get five dollars off the Lumi starter
pack with code OTR at Lumi deodorant.com
that equates to over 40 percent of your
starter pack when you visit Lumi
deodorant.com using the code OTR also he
was 12 years old and I think their
lifespan is only 12 to 13. so they just
they just had to yeah they just had to
put them down so it's like a grandpa
with Alzheimer's it was just better yeah
yeah yeah oh okay they needed to do it
they didn't need yeah just put them down
I don't want I don't want to go that far
but yeah yeah I had grandma with
Alzheimer's I think she should have left
way earlier yeah oh you know what's a
major time waster oh God you guys ever
go on IMDb and just look up everything
about certain movies while you're
watching the movie while you're watching
yo I do it all the time oh he's in this
movie you look up all the Goofs all the
trivia oh my God you connect actor dots
you're like oh he was in this and this
and this and this that's two dude that
takes a long time I was doing that with
the Captain Phillips y'all seen that one
oh that's a great movie
I started crying
yeah
but it's just it's real and it's very
little words yeah you seen it I haven't
seen it
yeah that's the champion movie oh you're
gonna like the ending because the end of
the Navy Seals come and this is one part
out that's probably one of my favorite
Parts because they're on a boat and the
Navy Seals on a raft and you see them
looking through the viewfinder thing or
the scope and it's like the chances of
hitting the guy is so slim but he pulls
the trigger and they timed it perfectly
and went and killed the [__]
We're not gonna watch it then yeah but
then you read the IMDb on that and it
talks about Captain Phillips in real
life was like an [__] or something
and then it makes you like why do they
gotta do that let me have the movie let
me have it like also I'm not thinking
further than that I'm not like oh
[__] yeah I want to meet Captain
Phillips now like no I just like the
[__] first of all I don't even know I
don't even want to know who guy is Tom
Hanks is that [__] that's how I
felt about like when I saw lean on me as
a kid I'm like I don't want to know
nothing about Joe Clark in real life
Jim's died right yeah and they're like
look up James you're wearing a piece of
[__] he was the [__] greatest NFL
player of all time probably yeah can we
just talk about that for a second isn't
he the logo I feel like he's spinning a
woman or some [__] now he did more than
spit at a woman yeah he did a lot
consensual spit bruh Jim Brown I mean
but also that was the time
different rules different rules but yeah
if you go through his Wikipedia it's all
like legal you go to legal issues it's
like a [__] wow but that's for
today's laws yeah yeah I just want to
keep the conversation on football if we
could
yeah hey do you when you're time wasting
do you watch a lot of like football
highlights or like yeah or just like old
times
nft stuff's my number one time moisture
because what do you guys consider a Time
waster though because if it is rewarding
is it really a waste there I mean I
don't gain anything from watching these
animal videos I think it's one of those
things where you if you feel good if you
look up if you snap out of it and you
realize how much time has passed that
qualifies I think but then
so what's the difference
between like going through like like a a
watch-a-thon for a series you like of of
a TV show there's not one I mean okay I
had a recent example of payoff right I
spent when I am chilling I love NFL
stuff football stuff I was recently at a
Super Bowl party and someone was like I
wonder what like the biggest Point
disparity in NFL history was and I was
like those Chargers versus the versus
Niners in the Super Bowl like early 90s
and they're like whoa he just knows that
and my wife's like he just [__] knows
everything about football and I'm like
yeah [__] yeah I guess that is
the reward that little moment yeah I
think a Time waster is when you had set
out to do something and then it pushed
you back I was building some [__]
Ikea furniture and then everyone keeps
telling me about the Chris Stapleton uh
uh uh
uh national anthem for for the football
for Super Bowl
you guys need to watch it no no we were
talking about it's one of the best
[__] national anthems ever oh we're
Whitney Houston Whitney Houston was the
best ever I was watching that and then I
was like oh damn this is really good so
I was like let me I went on a national
anthem
so I was watching national anthems from
everybody we did that with halftime show
did you get the fergies
it's one of the best ones and then I
started watching People's reacts to
national animals you know what I talk so
much [__] about reaction videos but I'm
always like how does everyone else feel
about this every [__] every time that
I'm like why am I watching this and then
I told myself I was gonna finish
building this thing so in the morning so
I could do something in the afternoon
yeah by the time I was done watching it
was like 3 P.M of course I'm like oh of
course so that was a time waster these
things are still pleasurable and they're
fun but I always do them when I should
be doing something yeah yeah if it
pushes real life back yeah yeah that's
when but meanwhile I won't even sit
there and watch TV like but I want like
like yeah TV's like a [__] strong and
I and I watch the same TV show over and
over what shows it shows of Anarchy
really like yeah what am I doing do you
want to get miles
yeah
you're a Sam Crow fellow yeah yeah nice
who's your favorite one great series my
favorite yeah ooh I'm Sons of Anarchy I
like juice uh probably chibs the
Scottish dude
oh he's good because he's a down ass
mofo yeah down ass mofo I see uh Charlie
Hunnam all the time on Runyon yeah he
kind of He he'll be out there working
out by himself and [__] and real nature
you ever call them Jacks
I know I bet he still gets that though
oh he gets yelled at every day hey Jax
yeah of course last show I watched was
the shield oh I want to watch that loved
this year it was good it's a great show
but I think the camera Works a little
whack now yeah yeah makes you nauseous a
little bit a little bit you want to know
a time waster that literally has no
redeeming quality I like looking up
Korean barbecue Yelps to see how many
people didn't understand that you cook
your own meat that's
also I barely find any so oh really yeah
that's not the same that's my follow-up
I told you guys over the years one of my
favorite things to do when it's time
waste remote or like if I have a party
and I have something I want to play in
the background I play the live camera of
the Abbey Road shot like that you can
get live in the UK you pull a beat of it
and there's always [__] like walking
the Middle Street trying to do the
[__] walks yeah and get their camera
and there's just angry British motors
like [__] yeah yeah
there's a live feed up there yeah that's
so funny so when I when I went there to
that spot I was like I'm not walking
across I was like yeah that was like why
do I need to do this like I see it it's
right there that's cool but I don't need
to [__] do they have a leaning tower
one where everyone's [__]
everyone does that oh my God right now
there's [__] trying to take this
look at this question
don't [__] wait it's the best this is
live bam
humans are so predictable that's so
great so you can get your photo of the
average because everybody thinks they're
[__] special yeah
oh my God imagine if that's your commute
daily not daily and you hate and it's
and it's people yeah it's people lined
up and it's always the camera guy
running out too yeah it's like oh and
the camera guy in front yep everyone
dude that's amazing yeah they should do
one for the pink wall too play the game
play the game yourself right now it's
about noon uh La time play the game
wherever you're at Abby Abbey Road live
Camp dude there's so much just Beatles
tourism though yeah like like there's
that Pub where they got started at
there's like Paul McCartney's house I
was shocked man I was like there's so
many Beetles like people that go to
Liverpool please
[__] dorks in a row yeah perfect
and there's always a car always dude
it's a very busy street is there a
Hollywood Highland life camp
because I'd want to see how many people
do tick tocks during the crossing oh
dude now I want to go and do this with
the careful boys
camera and we do it wrong and argue
about it we cause more traffic we can
never get the [__] photo yeah there's
no stop sign here
so oh wow dude yeah it's constant or
maybe like Anthony Lee's actually
accidentally in the photo we're like
what the [__] we gotta do it again
dude this is great I didn't know that
existed that's amazing that's such a
deep cut it's a deep cut that's a deep
cut
yeah that's a Time waster yeah for sure
but it's so enjoyable like watching all
these motors just have their day [__]
ruined and all these [__] getting
the same picture yes and they're all
trying to do they're like trying to make
sure it's the right way like oh you know
the Beatles are walking the Beatles
didn't [__] swing their arms out you
could just see their Cavs
doing like this [__] yeah like walking
like Nazis and I'm always like who's it
for your friends don't give a [__] they
don't give a [__] your friends give zero
[__] bucket list thing man a million
people have taken this picture like yeah
a year I bet yeah yeah see these [__]
stop in the middle oh yes
Frozen great deep cut down dude we're
not gonna have culture like this in a
long time no you know like like because
now it's like Tick-Tock age social media
age where like Trends come and go like
the type of impact that like Beatles
Michael Jackson would ever have I don't
think we're gonna have I know Beatles is
still going and that was like the only
like one of the biggest bands that
everybody was talking about yeah there's
so many subcultures where we're not
going to have this [__] oh yeah well no
yeah I don't think we'll ever have like
a Michael Jackson nah dude ever again
the closest thing we have is Drake
closest thing we have is Darude
Sandstorm
yeah memes are gonna take over like who
like who's who's bigger than Michael
Jackson right now the guy the guy who
made
the guy we don't know the name of yeah
we don't know who made it yeah see we
don't even know his name yeah not that
one there's like little kids like doing
like Michael like Michael Jackson
impersonator yeah
oh my God
dude that little Mogul maybe that was
crazy if Ryan's toy review bought the
Beatles catalog